engagé depuis 35 ans patrick planquer le
candidat de lutte ouvrière pour la 11e
circonscription des yvelines ouvriers de
maintenance sncf de 52 ans il tentera de
prendre la suite de nadia est
démissionnaire après sa nomination au
sein du gouvernement ce qui manque
aujourd'hui c'est un parti des
travailleurs ce qui manque aujourd'hui
c'est une organisation des travailleurs
qui défendent ce point de vue et qui
organise à l'échelle d'un quartier à
l'échelle d'une usine à l'échelle d'un
atelier la population laborieuse et qui
défendent ce point de vue là et moi
c'est pour ça que je fais de la
politique depuis très longtemps
suppléant lors du scrutin de 2010 est il
se porte candidat la municipale de
trappes de 2020 où il obtient 3 % des
voix à l'issue du premier tour
dans cette campagne il souhaite porter
le message est la voix des travailleurs
nous ce qu'on a toujours dénoncé dans
nos campagnes et dans notre activité
militante c'est de dire oui aujourd'hui
le capitalisme il est réellement
responsable de cette situation et c'est
bien à ça qu'on s'attaque aujourd'hui et
c'est ça qu'on veut défendre en
défendant le point de vue des
travailleurs pour ce scrutin la gauche
part divisée sandrine grands comptes
pour génération et valérie froberger
pour la france insoumise sont déclarés